if you find a mountain and you start climbing you
spend your whole life climbing it and you get say
two-thirds of the way and then you see the peak
is like way up there but you're two-thirds of the
way up you're still really high up but not to
go the rest of the way you're gonna have to go
back down to the bottom and look for another path
nobody wants to do that people don't want to start
over yeah and it's the nature of later in life
that you just don't know the time so it's very
painful to go back down and look for A New Path
but that may be the best thing to do and that's
why when you look at the greatest artists uh and
and creators they have this ability to start over
that nobody else does like Elon will you know be
called an idiot and start over doing something
brand new that he supposedly is not qualified for
or when Madonna or Paul Simon or YouTube come out
the new album their existing fans usually hate
it because they've adopted a completely new style
that they've learned somewhere else and a lot of
times they'll just miss completely so you have
to be willing to be a fool and kind of have that
beginner's mind and go back to the beginning to
start over if you're not doing that you're just
getting older Nivi just made the point to me on
the side that inspiration is perishable which is a
very good point when you have your inspiration do
it right then and there this happens to me a lot
with my tweet storms I've actually come up with a
whole bunch of additional tweets starting besides
the ones that are already out there but sometimes
it just hesitate or I just pause and then it just
dies and what I've learned is if I'm inspired to
write a blog post or to publish a tweet storm I
should probably do it right away otherwise it's
not gonna get out there I won't come back to it
so inspiration is a beautiful and powerful thing
and when you have it just seize it so people talk
about impatience when do you know to be impatient
when do you know to be patient my glib tweet on
this was impatience with actions and patience
with the results and I think that's actually a
good philosophy for Life anything you have to
do just get it done why wait you're not getting
any younger your life is slipping away you don't
want to spend it waiting in line you don't want to
spend it traveling back and forth you don't want
to spend it doing things that you know ultimately
aren't part of your mission and when you do them
you want to do them as quickly as you can while
while you do them well with your full attention
but then you just have to give up on the results
you have to be patient with the results because
you're dealing with complex systems you're
dealing with lots of people it takes a long
time for markets to adopt products it takes time
for people to get comfortable working with each
other it takes time for great products to emerge
as you polish away polish away polish away so
impatience with actions patients with results and
as Nivi said inspiration is perishable so when you
have inspiration act on it right then and there if
you stop trying to figure out how to do things the
way other people want you to do them then you'll
get to listen to that little voice inside of your
head that wants to do things a certain way and
then you get to be you and no one in the world
is going to beat you at being you you're never
going to be as good at being me as I am and I'm
never going to be as good at you being you as
you are so certainly listen absorb but don't
try and emulate it's a Fool's errand instead
each person is uniquely qualified at something
they have some specific knowledge capability
and desire that nobody else in the world does
this is purely from the combinatorics of human DNA
and development and so and so your goal in life
is to find out the people who need you the most to
find out the business that needs you the most find
the project and the art that needs you the most
because there's something out there just for you
but what you don't want to do is be building
checklists and decision Frameworks built on
what other people are doing because you're never
going to be there you'll never be good at being at
somebody else the whole phrase is what feels like
play to you but looks like work to others and all
those words are deliberately chosen like feels
like because it's your internal feeling like play
so it's fun but looks because the outside person
doesn't have the feel like work to them and if it
looks like work to them then you can monetize it
and it can be useful so all four of those pieces
are important in that sentence all of those
criteria have to be fulfilled for you to find
something that is a worthwhile Endeavor where
essentially it's your hobby but it's everybody
else's vocation it's your avocation their vocation
and that's how I know no one can compete with me
on it because I'm just playing 16 hours a day and
if they want to compete with me and they're going
to work they're going to lose because they're not
gonna do it 16 hours a day seven days a week a
happy person wants ten thousand things a sick
person just wants one thing right so it's your
it's your unlimited desires that are clouding
your peace your happiness have desires your
biological crazy sort of stands up and says
I can do something I I move I resist I live
but just be very careful of your desires this is
the oldest most right wisdom desire is suffering
that's what it means right every desire you
have is an access where you will suffer so
just don't focus on more than one desire at a
time the universe is rigged in such a way that
if you just want one thing and you focus on that
you'll get it but everything else you gotta let go
the reality is I don't actually read that much
compared to what people think like the re I
probably read one to two hours a day which and
that puts me in the top 0.0001 uh I think that
alone accounts for any material success that I've
had in my life and the intelligence that I might
have because real people don't read an hour a day
real people I think read a minute a day or less uh
so making it an actual habit is the most important
thing and how you make it a habit doesn't matter
it's very much like exercise or working out do
something every day it almost doesn't matter what
you do so the people who are obsessing over like
should I be weight training or should I be doing
tennis or should I be doing Pilates or should I
be doing the high intensity Training Method versus
the happy body versus whatever they're missing
the point the important thing is to do something
every day it doesn't matter what it is so the same
way I would argue the important thing is to read
every day and it's not it doesn't matter it almost
doesn't matter what you read because eventually
you'll read enough things and your interest will
lead you there that it will dramatically improve
your life so just like the best workout for you is
the one that you're excited enough to do every day
the same way I would say the best books to read
are the ones that are books or blogs or Twitter
or whatever anything with ideas and information
and learning the best ones to read are the ones
that you're excited about reading all the time
I'm actually an anti-social introvert and I was
just lost in the world of words and ideas from an
early age I think some of it comes from the happy
circumstance that when I was young nobody forced
me on what to read I think there's a tendency
among parents and teachers to say oh you should
read this but don't read that the reality is I
just read a lot that by today's standards would
be considered mental junk food but eventually
you just get to like reading you run out of the
junk food and then you start eating the healthy
food right or your tastes kind of graduate so I
think to some extent that's what happened with me
because I started from comic books and then run
from that into Mysteries and went from that into
fantasy you get into sci-fi and then from if I
admitted to science and then mathematics and then
philosophy so it just kind of kept climbing up the
stack but I'm lucky that there was no one around
when I was seven years old or 16 years old saying
oh you shouldn't read that you should read this
instead now what I realized is that the biggest
mistake was memorization right because when you're
actually trying to live your life in congruence
with reality you you want to have a deep
understanding of what you do and why you do it
and so it's much more important to know the basics
really well than is to know the advanced knowing
calculus wouldn't help you today it doesn't help
you in business doesn't help you in most things
but knowing arithmetic really will help you really
whether it's at the Corner Grocery Store counting
change to figuring out the value of your podcast
business to figuring out how to do the probability
math on you know some action that you want to take
so understanding basic mathematics cold is way
more important than memorizing calculus Concepts
and the problem is and this is true of I think
all reasoning it's much better to know the basics
from the ground up solid found Foundation of
understanding a steel frame of understanding that
is to just have a scaffolding which is memorizing
advanced concepts this is why there are a lot of
people I'm sure that you listen to who are really
smart they use a lot of jargon and you can't quite
follow their reasoning you don't know how they're
putting things together and you're this deep down
suspicion they don't even really understand right
so if you look at the the most powerful thinkers
especially the ones where money or life is on the
line they have to understand the basics really
really well Richard Feynman the physicist was able
to he had this piece in one of his lectures where
he takes you from counting numbers on your hand
all the way to calculus in four pages of text
in the orally but written Downs four pages of
text and it's a complete unbroken logical chain
that takes you through geometry trigonometry
precalculus analytic geometry graphs everything
all the way to calculus he understood numbers at
a core level he didn't have to memorize anything
when you're memorizing it's an indication that you
don't understand you should be able to re-derive
anything on the spot and if you can't you don't
know it so do you apply that to things other
than mathematics you apply that to everything
everything and the first thing if you're going
to make money is that you're not going to get rich
renting at your time there are many reasons for
that but the most basic is just that your inputs
are very closely tied to your output in almost any
salary job even a one that's paying a lot per hour
like a lawyer or a doctor you're still putting in
the hours and every hour you get paid so what that
means is when you're sleeping you're not earning
when you're retired you're not earning when you're
on vacation you're not earning and you can't earn
non-linearly if you look at even doctors who get
rich like really rich it's because they open a
business they open like a private practice and
that private practice builds a brand and that
brand attracts people or they build some kind of
a medical device or a procedure or a process where
they have intellectual property so essentially
you're working for somebody else and that person
is taking on the risk and has the accountability
and the intellectual property and the brand so
they're just not going to pay you enough they're
going to pay you the bare minimum that they have
to to get you to do the job and that can be a
high bare minimum but it's still not going to be
true wealth where you're retired shared and then
finally you're not creating new things for society
you're just doing things over and over and you're
essentially replaceable because you're now doing a
set role most set roles can be taught if they can
be taught like in a school then eventually you'll
be competing with someone who's got more recent
knowledge who's been taught and is coming in to
replace you you're much more likely to be doing
a job that can be eventually replaced by a robot
or by an AI and it doesn't have to be wholesale
replaced overnight it can be replaced a little
bit of a time and that eats into your wealth
creation and therefore your earning capability
so fundamentally your inputs are matched to your
outputs you are replaceable and you're not being
creative I just don't think that that is a way
that you can truly make money so the first thing
you have to do is you have to own a piece of
a business you need to have Equity either as
an owner an investor shareholder or a brand that
you're building that accrues to you to gain your
financial freedom so this newest form of Leverage
is where all the new fortunes are made so all the
new billionaires the last generation fortunes were
made by Capital that was the Warren buffets of the
world but the new generation fortunes Are All Made
through code or media Joe Rogan making 50 to 100
million bucks a year from his podcasts PewDiePie I
don't know how much money he's rolling in but he's
bigger than the news right the Fortnite players
of course Jeff Bezos and Mark Zuckerberg and Larry
Page and Sergey Brin and Bill Gates and Steve Jobs
that is all code based leverage probably the most
interesting thing to keep in mind about the new
forms of Leverage is they are permissionless they
don't require somebody else's permission for
you to use them or succeed for labor leverage
somebody has to decide to follow you for Capital
leverage somebody has to give you money to invest
or to turn into a product but coding writing books
recording podcasts tweeting youtubing these kinds
of things these are permissionless you don't need
anyone's permission to do them and that that's why
they're very egalitarian they're great equalizers
of Leverage and it's really it's actually really
important to have empty space if you don't have
a day or two days a week in your calendar where
you're not always in meetings and you're not
always busy then you're not going to be able to
think you're not going to have good ideas for your
business you're not going to have good judgments
so I also encourage taking at least one day a week
preferably two because if you budget two you'll
end up with one uh a day a week where you have
nothing on your calendar and you just have time to
think um it's only after you're bored that you're
gonna have the great ideas uh it's never going to
be when you're stressed or busy or running around
or rushed so make the time to me the real winners
are the ones who step out of the game entirely
who don't even play the game Who rise above it
and those are the people who have such internal
mental and self-control and self-awareness that
they need nothing from anybody else so there are a
couple of these characters that I know in my life
um some older gentlemen that I like to kind of
learn from and we mentioned our polish friend
earlier I would consider him successful because
he doesn't need anything from anybody yeah he
is at peace he is at health and whether he makes
more money or less money or with the next person
over from him does better or worse than him has
no effect on his mental state and bearing and
historically I would say that the legendary Buddha
or Krishna Morty Who stuff that I like reading
they are successful quote unquote in the sense
that they step out of the game entirely winning or
losing does not matter to them there's some line
that I read somewhere that all of man's troubles
arise uh because he cannot sit in a room quietly
by himself for a half an hour right and if if you
could literally just sit if you could just sit for
30 minutes and be happy you were successful uh and
I think that that is a that is a very powerful
place to be but very few of us get there now
let me leave you with some words from Steve Jobs
Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger on some of these
rules be ready to start over Steve Jobs said I
didn't see it then but it turned out that getting
fired from Apple was the best thing that could
have ever happened to me the heaviness of being
successful was replaced by the lightness of being
a beginner again less sure about everything it
freed me to enter one of the most creative periods
of my life do what feels like play but looks like
work similar to this Steve Jobs said don't be a
career the enemy of most dreams and intuitions
and one of the most dangerous and stifling
Concepts ever invented by humans is the career
a career is a concept for how one is supposed to
progress through stages during the training four
and practicing of your working life there are
some big problems here first and foremost is a
notion that your work is different and separate
from the rest of your life if you're passionate
about your life and your work this can't be so
they will become more or less one this is a much
better way to live one's life overcome the need
for external validation Warren Buffett said would
you rather be the world's greatest lover but have
everyone think you're the world's worst lover or
would you rather be the world's worst lover but
have everyone think you're the world's greatest
lover your answer to this question will tell
you whether you're doing things for the sake
of external valuation or for the sake of your own
driven passion fall in love with reading Charlie
Munger reads around 500 non-fiction books every
year he said the following in my whole life I have
known no wise people who didn't read all the time
none zero you would be amazed at how much Warren
reads and at how much I read my children laugh
at me they think I'm a book with a couple of
legs sticking out Navarro vacant has also said
that it's not about educated versus uneducated
it's about likes to read and doesn't like to read
personally my main three sources of learning are
videos and podcasts books and the book summary app
short form which I explained next show from create
super insightful study guides from hundreds
of non-fiction books and it has helped me to
discover and learn ideas much faster the cost
is equivalent to the price of one book a month
and you can use my affiliate link shortform.com
picking nuggets to get a 5 day free trial and a
20 discount on the annual subscription you can
also find the link in the description below